le
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est dans le cadre de la
16ème édition des
la fin de la nature on accueille le
public donc qui viennent découvrir en
fait cet espace naturel sensible qui est
le domaine fleuri
[Musique]
deux remarques sur ce site c'est des
espèces
en demies la caractéristique eux
son protégé
on peut voir comme espèce l'arctique
[Musique]
cette forêt semi-sèche pouvoir le
joindre
[Musique]
quand date le pinacle
le bois de
boitard net
le bois de lys blancs un cortège
floristique
on va dire assez c'est face on est sur
les plus anciens sol de l'île de la
réunion
c'est l'altération fêtes de la roche
donc avec
le climat donc l'intérêt du sol qui a
donné un petit peu ces différentes
colorations donc ici on est sur des sols
on va dire des andes au sol et des sols
qui rallie tic qui donne cette légère
coloration un petit peu brun pour les
gens de sol effet khalid sheik un peu
rouge
on va dire en couleurs faire couleur
rouille donc ici sur le site donc c'est
un sol qui a été très très très lessivé
[Musique]
découvrir des lieux qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément
voilà ici surtout bien l'expliquer par
les guides qui ont toutes les
connaissances scientifiques y
donc c'est très intéressant
[Musique]